all right as we go through tonight's
opening monologue I want you to keep
some very important questions in your
mind first think about this what is
worse a hostile regime that we know is
hostile run by a bad actor trying to
create chaos in our elections as it has
many times in the past or top officials
in the Federal Bureau of Investigation
rigging an investigation to advance
their favored candidate that they should
have indicted what about the Democratic
Party rigging their own party's primary
to favor Hillary Clinton over Bernie
Sanders what's worse or is it worse that
the Democratic Party bought and paid for
Russian lies of all things to
propagandize you the American electorate
the American people to lie outright to
you the American people about an
opposing candidate rather than win on
the important issues that will impact
the lives of the American people or is
it worse that the Democrats the DNC and
Hillary Clinton that they actually
bought and paid for what turned out to
be Russian lies presented as the bulk of
information to secure a FISA warrant on
an American citizen associated with an
opposition party in a presidential
election year so they could spy on that
party and a warrant based on Russian
paid for lies or is it worse the
Democratic Party bought and paid for
those Russian lies they were never
verified and yet regurgitated by the
self-righteous sanctimonious delusional
media in this country that exalts itself
as something they are not as they claim
to be unbiased and fair when they're
nothing but the cheerleaders and
Crusaders for all things that only
matter to the Democratic Party and
liberal causes and ask yourself what's
the worst thing that happened in
Helsinki yesterday that the president
began a conversation with the second
largest nuclear power in the world about
let's see nuclear proliferation radical
Islamic terrorism innocent people
slaughtered daily in Syria the ongoing
civil war
Iranian aggression oh and by the way
where is the DNC server where is that
server that the FBI didn't look at where
are those 33,000 deleted emails on Yoga
wedding a funeral where are they now the
media you know they wanted what they
wanted Obama like promises to Vladimir
that he'll show more flexibility from
Trump to Putin and of course president
Trump has long stated that good
international relationships with our
friends and our geopolitical foes is a
very good thing for everybody
simple truth now this is especially true
when nuclear weapons are in play and
unfortunately prior to yesterday's
summit us-russia relations they were
incredibly strained and while President
Trump tried to ease these tensions and
carve out some kind of working
diplomatic channel with Vladimir Putin
well your mainstream media they were out
for blood
even before the president arrived and if
you thought the rhetoric in the vitriol
coming from America's abusively biased
press was bad well tonight it has become
so much worse we have Holocaust
comparisons Pearl Harbor references
calls for revolution in this country and
much more you don't believe me we have
the tape if the president did that today
because he has some reason to serve that
other country rather than our own then
well then a lot that has previously been
inexplicable is now explicable and
that's the worst case scenario it's just
as serious to me as the Cuban Missile
Crisis in terms of an attack or the 9/11
attack his performance today will live
in infamy as much as the Pearl Harbor
attack or Kristallnacht when do we see
almost a shadow government come out and
say we cannot side with the government
whether it's the cabinet or the Senate I
think that's the big question
you stood next to that man and you said
it and gained the middle finger to
America that's right we now have to
figure out how to deal with a President
of the United States who wittingly or
unwittingly has been
compromised what we saw yesterday was
collusion winning or unwitting in the
president's words and attitudes toward
the president looked like a weak dumpy
stooge to a KGB spy get a chance to show
loyalty to the men and women in uniform
of America's military and Intel
community and instead he betrayed them
somebody needs to make it clear to
President Trump that his behavior it in
that press conference was an American
outrageous ridiculous stupid you had a
one-word reaction to what you saw
yesterday treason treason yeah alright
9/11 Pearl Harbor you know I'm normally
kind of immune to the media's daily dose
of feigned moral outrage but this is
sick and it's now pathological really
sick now this is not news these people
are not journalists these are not news
channels what you just saw is nothing
but left-wing propaganda misinformation
it's just that plain obvious and simple
and naturally you have former communists
turned CIA director turned MSNBC
conspiracy theorist John Brennan also
chiming in with more propaganda of his
own take a look I think there's a big
question first of all in terms of those
who are on mr. Trump's national security
team whether they can continue to serve
in good conscience an individual who
basically betrayed his nation what mr.
Trump did yesterday was to betray the
women men of the FBI the CIA NSA and
others and to betray the American public
and that's why I use the term that this
is nothing short of treasonous because
it is a betrayal of the nation he is
giving aid and comfort to the enemy and
it needs to stop and mr. Trump needs to
understand that they're going to be
consequences for him too can't wait to
get to all of Brennan's nefarious
activities because it's all going to
come out I mean while Brennan's former
deep state partner in crime James Comey
tweeted out quote this was the day an
American president stood on foreign soil
next to a murderous lying thug and
refused to back his own country patriots
need to stand up and reject the behavior
of this president Jim we reject your
behavior
your behavior your abuse of power that
rightly got you fired so there you have
it you have to indignant anti-trump
former bureaucrats chastising the
president all while they knew about
Russia's attempts to meddle in our
elections by the way it happened on
their watch they did nothing to sound
the alarm all because they thought their
chosen candidate that's right Jim helped
Hillary remember was she they thought
she was gonna win we'll have more on
that in a moment but first let's break
down one key issue and that is Comey
Brennan and the media they're losing it
absolutely lost their minds the topic of
Russian sponsored election hacking well
today President Trump clarified his
remarks from the summit made it
perfectly clear that he trusts our Intel
agencies not the ones that work before
and their reports on Russian election
meddling and by the way I have the proof
I'll show you in a second take a look I
have full faith and support for
America's great intelligence agencies
always had and I have felt very strongly
that while Russia's actions had no
impact at all on the outcome of the
election let me be totally clear and
saying that and I've said this many
times I accept our intelligence
community's conclusion that Russia's
meddling in the 2016 election for the
place other people now in case the left
forgot what you just saw from President
Trump is a position that he has clearly
articulated over and over and over and
over again and if your media had any
honesty in them they would remind you
they would do their job but as usual
will do their job for them so here's the
president having said it this many times
and more take a look as far as hacking I
think it was Russia but I think we also
get hacked by other countries and other
people and I can say that you know when
when we lost twenty-two million names
and everything
else that was actually said late they
didn't make a big deal out of that that
was something that was extraordinary
that was probably China we had we have
much hacking going on well I think it
was Russia and I think it could have
been other people and other countries
could have been a lot of people
interfered I think it was Russia but I
think it was probably other people
and/or countries it was Russia and I
think it was probably others also the
Russians had no impact on our votes
whatsoever but certainly there was
meddling and probably there was meddling
from other countries and maybe other
individuals so immediate didn't believe
them but he had set it over and over and
over and over and over again we all know
the Russians have been meddling in our
elections we know that Russia is a
hostile regime we all know that Putin is
a bad actor and today now the Trump is
the president all of a sudden the left
seems to care now let's just slow down
for a moment and let's discuss this
blatant hypocrisy because in 2008 there
was Russian hacking into the McCain
campaign and the Obama campaign but at
the time it cornered very little
attention and in 2012 as President Obama
gearing up for his big re-election bid
remember he was overheard on a hot mic
telling then Russian President Medvedev
that he'd have more more flexibility
don't tell the American people have more
flexibility after the election
sounds like collusion
[Music]
now of course following that incident
there was no outrage from the left in
this country no hysteria virtually no
one in the mainstream media accused
Obama of being Vladimir Putin's puppet
in that case puppet
anyway months later during a
presidential debate Barack Obama
ridiculed Mitt Romney's warning about
the Russia threat
Romney was right take a look Governor
Romney I'm glad that you recognized that
al-qaeda is a threat because a few
months ago when you were asked what's
the biggest geopolitical threat facing
America you said Russia not al-qaeda you
said Russia and the 1980s are now
calling to ask for their foreign policy
back because you know the Cold War has
been over for 20 years no of course he
thought global warming was the big
geopolitical threat and again the
mainstream media they barely on remember
2014 house Intel Committee Chairman
Devin Nunez he sounded the alarm about
Russia's malicious intentions to cause
chaos around the world in the 2016
elections here in America throughout his
presidency Obama warned by our own Intel
services about Russia meddling he did
nothing 2016 there's Obama eight years
of weakness telling Donald Trump to quit
whining that a US election no serious
person thought it could possibly be
rigged in any way stop whining take a
look there is no serious person out
there who would suggest somehow that you
could even you could even rig America's
elections in part because they're so
decentralized and the numbers of votes
involved there's no evidence that that
has happened in the past or that there
are instances in which that will happen
this time and so I'd advise mr. Trump to
stop whining and go try to make his case
to get votes okay it did happen in the
past and it did happen in spite of him
saying it couldn't happen
and by the way Obama knew there was
Russia meddling and he did nothing and
he told us it couldn't happen and then
he dropped the ball and the media didn't
hold him accountable and following the
election in 2016 President Obama
even stated publicly that shaming Putin
publicly would not be an effective
tactic which now the media thinks was
necessary or you're not a patriot take a
look and I should point out by the way
part of why the Russians have been
effective on this is because they don't
go around announcing what they're doing
it's not like Putin's going around the
world publicly saying look what we did
wasn't that clever he denies it so the
idea that somehow public shaming is
going to be effective I think doesn't
read the the thought process in Russia
very well of course she was the anointed
one and immediate eight years kissed his
know you know and where was the media
hysteria over that why now why President
Trump now of course the Obama
administration's policy was much worse
than its rhetoric Obama did nothing to
counter Vladimir Putin's aggression and
his actions in Crimea Ukraine Obama did
nothing when Rogers Russia dropped
literally showed up an Assad and started
helping that dictator butcher what
hundreds of thousands of Syrian men
women and children that happened on
Obama's watch he did nothing as Russia
work with Iran to destabilize the entire
Middle East instead Obama signed off on
that insane horrific Iranian nuclear
deal sending cargo planes with a hundred
and fifty billion dollars in cash and
other currency to the mullahs in Iran by
the way while they were chanting death
to America death to Israel burning our
flag the Israeli flag funding terrorism
around the world and all of this
meddling all this interference was on
Obama clappers Brennan and commis watch
not Donald Trump's he's cleaning up
their mess and according to reports in
order to secure the Iranian deal Obama
even looked the other way
as the terrorist group Hezbollah funded
their terrorist activities through drug
trafficking deals in the US and despite
all of this no outrage from the media in
this
country in fact they were cheering for
Obama every single step of the way but
now the media is desperate they didn't
think Trump would win the primary they
didn't they gave win the general
election they thought collusion would
get him and Robert Muller would nail
them but that's not working so now
they're conspiracy theories have gone on
steroids and human growth hormone
meanwhile in this very important time we
all know that there was Russia collusion
in the 2016 presidential election we
know about Putin we know about Russia
now by the way it surrounds Hillary
Clinton in the 2016 campaign not Donald
Trump Hillary paid a foreign spy
funneled money through a law firm a
foreign spy to put together unverified
would turn out to be Russian lies
Russian propaganda about Donald Trump
disseminated that material now known as
the dossier throughout the federal
government throughout Obama's Justice
Department into the FBI the US Senate
and even used by the Obama
administration of garner FISA warrants
on a trump campaign associate so they
can spy on that campaign in the middle
of a presidential election by the way
there's a real story of Russia collusion
that is what the media will not report
the biggest abuse of power corruption
scandal in our history and the press is
also refusing to cover the ongoing deep
state scandal surrounding look at this
least the Paige and Peter struck now the
biased of high-ranking FBI employees
there at the very center of the 2016
effort to literally clear their chosen
candidate Hillary Clinton of all charges
all felonies she committed all
obstruction she's guilty of while
investigating a Russia witch-hunt to
take down Donald Trump during our
interview last night here's what
President Trump had to say about the
corrupt lovebirds struck in Page take a
look you have to find out who did Peter
struck report to because it was coming
and it was McCain but it was also
probably Obama if you think that Obama
didn't know what was going when you
watch and I said it today with President
Putin when you watch Peter strux
performance the lover of Lisa Paige when
you watch that performance the FBI I'll
tell you I know so many people in the
these are incredible people what they
have to what they're going through
watching this guy a total phony I mean
how about we'll stop it or something to
that